what is customs duty hello my name is
too cute I design rocket-propelled
clothes I came to earth because I am
fascinated by your shoes there is no
such thing on my planet I have a great
idea I will design rocket-propelled
shoes Europeans love shoes I will make
my shoes in the European Union but if I
set up a business I think I will have to
pay custom duties I want to know what
custom duties ears
[Music]
[Music]
you are in ancient Greece during the war
Wow
the battle started the soldiers are very
brave why are the citizens paying they
paid us fora taxes to buy weapons and to
pay the costs of keeping and managing
the army what happens at the end of the
war at the end of the war the citizens
stopped paying these taxes and they
receive goods captured during the war
welcome to the Roman Empire you have to
pay poor torria to sell your goods and
to enter the city why do I have to pay
it because poor torria is a customs duty
applied to imported goods in the Roman
Empire customs duties were called port
area from Porter which is Latin for gate
each city or region set its own taxes
that's interesting welcome to medieval
times in the 14th and 15th centuries who
were those people they are German barons
they are very rich and powerful what are
they doing there they demand that people
pay them customs duties they had strong
castles and soldiers on the banks of the
River Rhine to control all water traffic
and anyone who travelled or carried
goods on the Rhine had to pay taxes to
pass through these customs points it
seems that everywhere in time you have
to pay taxes what about nowadays are we
still paying taxes yes of course but
there is a duty free customs union
between the EU Member States this means
that when goods move from one EU country
to another you don't pay customs tax but
member countries apply customs duties
for goods coming from countries outside
the European Union but there is so much
stuff coming and going this is foreign
trade import and export the amount of
goods moving between member countries or
entering the union is growing fast
EU imports and exports add up to over
3.4 trillion euros annually that's about
16 percent of world trade
every minute 4200 tons of goods enter
the EU imports or are sent from the EU
exports and over 500 customs
declarations are processed Wow
that is amazing
[Music]
[Music]
why are we still using custom duties
today why is it important to check good
so carefully and to charge custom duties
for goods entering EU territory
I will check to see one making sure
Goods meet EU and Byron mental health
and safety rules for example no
contaminated food or potentially
dangerous electrical appliances getting
into the EU to strict control over trade
in rare species of animals and plants
from endangered areas or checking that
animals are transported properly 3
keeping EU citizens healthy and safe and
protecting their jobs at EU businesses
by fighting piracy and counterfeit cards
for checking cultural items to make sure
that European cultural assets valuable
paintings sculptures Oh coins
archaeological pieces etcetera are not
illegally taken out of the EU 5 checking
that sensitive technologies or materials
that could be used to make nuclear or
chemical weapons are being legally
exported 6 supporting police and
Immigration Services in the fight
against terrorism and organized crime
such as drugs
firearms or trafficking in human beings
7 checking that people who travel with
large amounts of cash are not guilty of
money laundering or tax evasion when
entering or leaving the EU with 10000
euros or more one needs to declare this
to customs authorities there are a lot
of important reasons for paying customs
duties
my new phone is here I have already paid
300 euro to the store online do I have
to pay anything else as your parcel came
from outside the EU and its value
exceeds 150 euros you have to pay v80
and customs duties does this apply to
every import for goods whose value does
not exceed a certain amounts 10 euros
for some goods depending on the country
Novi 80 or customs duties are payable
for imports with a value between 10
euros and 150 euros no custom duties are
to only V 80 for imports with a value of
more than 150 euros v 80 and customs
duties are due depending on the type of
product in the countries V 80 rate
you